so to talk about other tools that you
might use for prototyping we brought in
Cody from pixate other so Cody what is
pixate picks it is a prototyping
platform definitely use for more intense
animations or detailed animations
interactions also but it's all done
natively so on the device that you're
prototyping for you get the same effects
on scroll views on the animations
anything that you would normally see in
an app we can reproduce their pics eight
perfect that's wonderful so it sounds
like it's good at these sort of higher
fidelity prototypes it's good at these
like micro interactions and getting
things right when you're doing some
small part of the app right it
definitely focuses on reproducing a real
experience within the app as opposed to
maybe ones that are more you know like
paper for instance or anything like that
where it you don't get the full feeling
of it what you can do is when you
prototype through pixate you can
basically hand this over to someone a
developer someone maybe you're selling
the app to and show them exactly how you
expect it to work as the designer so a
tool like pixate would make it much
easier to have the design consultation
will be doing later on in lesson so Cody
why are micro interactions important for
a prototype micro interactions are
really important from the design aspect
because you want to show exactly the
animations the movement of the different
elements within the app to give everyone
a better idea of what you're trying to
build on what you kind of envision as
the designer so what kind of questions
you get from entrepreneurs about your
product a lot of questions we get are
related to what to do with it once
you've created a prototype I feel like
that may be kind of a pain point for
some people because here they have this
design and they can show it to whomever
however they get to hand this over to a
developer now and show them exactly the
animations are looking for and the
developer for the most part can can
translate that over to code and then
generate the app from there okay so once
you've built a prototype you get a lot
of questions about what to do with it
and your suggestions are pretty much
have it built mm-hmm that's correct yeah
I just build it just hand it over to the
developer and build from there we want
to work on obviously
ways to improve that process like giving
in code export or you know other
features like that which we're kind of
you know working on alongside other
features but ultimately right now the
best way to do it is to just show them
okay perfect so we've covered what you
do once you've gotten the pics a
prototype what is the process for
getting into the pics a prototype you
know let's say we've got people who have
an envision prototype or have a set of
screens that have already been made what
do they do to get that into pixate
ideally the best way to do it is so the
way the pics eight works as it works
solely with assets assets being images
or soon actually video and things like
that what they want to do is take that
information or that those images they
have through envision those screens and
transfer them into sketch Photoshop
anything like that and then from that
point they can put it into pics a create
them as individual layers and start
playing around with creating those
interactions perfect thank you thank you
for coming in Cody not a problem at all
thank you